all right what do you got dick all right
let's get into the episode man so I want
to do a test I think you guys would
appreciate its a blind burger taste test
oh I knew you'd like it
are you down to try some burgers oh yeah
all right I'm vegetarian oh there's
somebody difficult and do not cheat
Brendan I'll try not to bro you look
like some cops fat horse somebody's but
you look like weekend at Jerry Sandusky
hey I can only picture you look like it
you look you look like you trade pogs
for dick pics Yeah right
Yeah right then well agree the slammer
you just get a sneak peek at your dick
oh let me hold your dick for a second
dude it's not gay if you hold somebody's
dick for a little more off you trade for
pogs bro so in front of you we've got
four burgers staples oh I smell umbra
yeah yeah and they're on individual
plates so you're not peak Brendan I'm
not dude you will you're the kind of guy
who would freakin cheat on something
like this no you're gonna cheat dude
well yeah they're in a line in front of
Brendan and then the other one so what's
the contest
yeah yeah it's Tripel pass into you hey
these feel like some nice tip
feeling I'm out bro hi there burgers you
know what they feel like yeah you've got
four burgers staples I would say just
take a bite or two of each one and then
kind of rank them for us there are four
different burgers yeah four burger
staples it's a burger yeah we had extra
for you Chappelle oh so what do i do
just bite in new we loves chin just bite
into it and then I would we also have a
paper towels on can't see you [ __ ] yeah
but I can imagine do not tell me what
they are yeah I think I think guess at
the end what you think they are along
with your ranking yeah yeah there you go
Wow you don't have a nice vanilla shake
to watch this down and these are for
mainstream yeah is everyone play no
justice dismiss here Brendon has all the
burgers oh my god everyone cuz I thought
the first thing with this company meet
me at 240 dog I don't think he's gonna
be able make it anymore
if you don't shut up you have sauce on
your arms I can't see that don't eat the
toothpick either Brendon you're safe no
tooth but my god old ladies is driving
you know
I need to know what for no see that's
not fair
first just rank them and then we'll tell
you what you picked hey don't eat them
all bro I got no food 2014 yeah just
dock want you to starve to death
Chappelle okay this isn't about you
Chappelle because I'm people out there
that are really starving and you're
giving them they think oh this guy's a
clown [ __ ] I'll tell what I could
really use a diet coke
Fat Boy where the diet and what are we
judging I thought it was which one is
McDonald's one two three four we should
have done this with whiskey but somebody
here's a [ __ ] quitter
whiskey's for gay men brought grab a
[ __ ] gram son alright and see you two
grab a netball how about you do both
brah
no yeah can you fly off the [ __ ]
hinges and murder everybody in here yeah
well everyone CD a great way off so you
feel there's also we give feel whiskey's
trying to suck this off saying it's not
gay we bought you four burgers you still
won't this is just another throat
Christmas were throwing for you and you
can't pipe down
I need him not sniffing right do what
brandon has his order vo yeah if you
want to put them in the order can I take
my glasses off yes no shake shack you
both put number one and you both put in
and out for oh my god Wow
so proof and then number two was five
guys and three was McDonald's Wow you're
number two has lettuce on it right yeah
yeah that's that's five guys and then
McDonald's so we went Shake Shack Shake
Shack Five Guys McDonald's in and out
and you want to read that's that's
that's why that's crazy that's crazy
samesies burger boys huh the Patty boys
you know that's close your
[Music]
the king
[Music]